Mary here with a gamespot news update  Hideo Kojima has released new images of  a metal gear solid figurine and let's  get right to the point she's got giant  squishy boobies series creator Hideo  Kojima tweeted out a few images of the  quiet figurine he says it all has some  soft materials that enable parts to be  pushed and lifted LOL quiet a female  sniper from Metal Gear Solid the phantom  pain has already been the focus of some  controversy due to her skimpy outfit in  2013 kajima responded to the criticism  saying I created her character as an  antithesis to the women characters who  appeared in the past fighting game who  are excessively exposed once you  recognize the secret reason for her  exposure you will feel ashamed of your  words and deeds be sure to tweet at my  boss ty route because I'm trying to get  them to pre-order the doll that I can do  an unboxing and squishing later this  year so if you want to see that be sure  to head the gamespot com flash news